[음악]
안녕하세요 시드 웨어입니다 제 주변은
웬만해서 옷에 관심 있는 사람들이라
그런지 이런 질문을 서로 종종합니다
평생 한 브랜드만 입어야 한다면 어떤
걸 입을 거야 좀 쓸데없는 질문이긴
하지만 그 순간만큼은 다들 귀엽도
진지해 져요 이런 질문을 받을 때마다
최근 몇 년 동안 제 대답은
한결같습니다
르메르 오늘 풀어볼 보리는 르메르
대한
메르는 동명의 디자이너 크리스토프
르메르 그리고 사라린트란 전개하고
있는 프랑스
브랜드입니다 우아한 실루엣으로
유명하면서 또 매일 입을 수 있는
옷을 표방하는만큼 실용성을 놓치지
않고자 하는 브랜드인데요 과거에
르메르 쇼들을 보면 뭐 출퇴근길의
사람들처럼 모델들의 동선이 막 가지
각이고 누구는 멈춰 있고 누구는 또
서로 대화하는 걸 볼 수가 있어요
쇼를 보면 중간에 비가 오는 연출을
해서 기능성 옷을 보여주는 등 비단
미적인 요소만 신경 쓰지 않는 걸
엿볼 수가 있습니다 제가 르메르를
알고 좋아하게 된 계기는 많은 분들과
다르지 않을 듯해요 르메르의 예전
트위스트 대님을 보고 브랜드를 알게
됐다가 유니클로 유로 가성비 좋은
제품들을 소비하다 결국은 메르로
진입하게 됐습니다 제가 르메르를
좋아하는 이유는 하지만 과하지 않고
트렌드에 구해지 않아서 시즌이 지나도
언제든지 입기 좋기
때문입니다 그리고 르메리 입었을 때
시너지가 굉장히 좋아요 물론 다른
브랜드들도 그러겠지만 르메르의 옷을
딱 봤을 때는 어느 옷에나 잘
어울리는 무난한 옷이라는 생각이
들잖아요 그런데 르를끼리 입었을 때
그 특유의 우아함이 가장 큰 빛을
보여주는 것 같습니다 메르는 제
옷장에서 큰 지분을 차지하고 있는데요
다 소개하는 건 영상이 너무 길어질
것 같아서 그중 소중한 제품 몇
가지를 골라서 이야기해 보려 합니다
처음 소개해드릴 제품은 르메르의 이사
SS 시즌 드라이 시크 셋업 중
라이트 미스티 그레이 컬러입니다
드라이 실크는 르메르를 대표하는 소재
중 하나인데요 이사 SS 시즌에만
드라이 실크 제품이 약 30개가
나왔습니다 드라이 실크는 실크랑
나일론 홈방 소재인데요
잔주름과이 흐르는 실루엣이 정말
매력적입니다 혹시 드라이 실크를 접해
보지 못한 분들은 꼭 입어 보시는 걸
추천드려요이 몸에 닿는 느낌이 굉장히
신기하면서
부드럽습니다 드라이 실크가 관리는 좀
쉽지 않아요 아무래도 실크 혼방
인지라 봄여름 소재긴 하지만 땀에는
취약한 편입니다 만약에 입으신다면
에어리즘 같은 내일을 꼭 입어 주시고
완연한 여름보다는 봄에 좀 더
추천드려요 제가이 제품에 큰 추억이
하나 있는데요 올해 4월에 제가
르메르를 담당하고 있을 때 한남
르메르 플래그십 행사에 참석해야
했습니다 그런데 참석자는 전부
르메르를 입어야 했어요 머리부터
발끝까지 물론 이전 시즌 제품이 몇
개 있었지만 그래도 이사스 시즌
제품으로 입는게 좋을 듯해서 드라이
실크 제품들을이 기회에 구매했습니다
제 나름대로 멋지게 드라이 실크
셋업을 딱 입고 갔는데 케이터링
서빙을 하시는 분들이 전부 저랑
똑같은 옷을 입고 계신 거예요 덕분에
몇 차례 서빙을 해보는 기회를 누릴
수
있었습니다 아무튼 중요한 건이 행사에
본국 사람들이 왔다는 거예요 그 말인
즉슨 크리스토프 르메르 사라가 왔다는
겁니다 인터뷰도 많고 또 대화하는
사람도 많다 보니까 저는 행사가 거의
끝나기 직전에야 크리스토프와 몇 마디
나눌 수
있었어요 어 잔뜩 먹어 들어가는
목소리로 I work for
you라고 외친 기억이 아직
생생한데요 정말 하고픈 말이 많았는데
완전히
얼어버렸습니다 그래도 다행히 르메르
전시에서 구매한 사진에 사인을
받아왔습니다이 방에 놔두고 이따 음식
봐요 어 메리시 초이 라니 혼자
추억하면서 너무 긴장해서 뒷장에 받아
버리긴 했지만 그래도 제 보물 1호에
등극한
물건입니다 같이 소개해드릴 제품은
르메르의 이사이 시즌 릴렉스드
트위스티드 가디건입니다 르메르의 많은
제품들이 그러하지만이 제품 또한 거의
몇 시즌 출시하는 상품 중 하나입니다
가리곤 특성상 사시사철 입기 좋고
색상도 언제든 잘 어울려서 이따금씩
꺼내 입게 되는 제품인 데요 어
재질에 있어서 드라이 실크가 르메르의
시그니처라이 제품은 르메르의 자주
선보이는 트위스티드 디테일에 넣은
제품입니다 이바 세대 기준 오른쪽
허리춤에 달린 단추와 체결하면 좀
멋을 부릴 수 있습니다 저는이
가디건의 색상이 마음에 들어서 입는
지라 트위스트의 형태로 자주 입지
않아요 가끔 좀 이옷을 뽐내고 싶을
때나 단추를 상대적으로 어색한 위치에
끼고 다니는데 근데 이거 녹음하면서
보니까 단추도 원래 저렇게 끼는게
아니더라고요 사실 트위스티드 디테일은
상위도 그렇지만 바지가 굉장히
유명합니다 꾸준히 나오는 트위스티드
베이티드 대들이 그러한데요 몇 년
전까진 기장이 짧고 좀 과장된
테이퍼대 핏으로 나오다가 22 SS
시즌부터 기장도 여유롭고 실루엣도
보다 자연스러운 형태로
변모했습니다 스럽 않으면서 르메르의
우아한 실을 잘 보여주는 바디라서
주변에 르멜 옷을 처음 구매하려는
사람들이 있을 때 항상 추천하는
제품입니다 이번에는 아마 더 추워지면
같이 많이 입을 계획인 두 제품을
소개해 드리려 합니다 먼저 말씀드릴
제품은 2fw 시즌에 출시한 르메르의
맥시 더플 코트입니다 이건 저를 위한
생일 선물로 올해 초 시즌오프 때
르메르 공식 홈페이지에서 구매했어요
제가 르메르의 제품 중 좀 두툼한
겨울 아우터를 찾고 찾다가 결국은이
제품에 정착하게 됐습니다 메르에서
가을겨울에 자주 출시하는 더플
코트인데이 2fw 시즌 제품은 스탠드
컬라 형태로 되어 있습니다 뭐 비조
있거나 아니면 후드가 달린 더플
코트가 대다수인데 이들과 차별점을 줄
수 있어요 그리고 스탠드 컬라이긴
하지만 전부 체결에도 하지 않은
정도입니다 더플 코트의 상징인이
토일도 코팅이 들어가서 고급지고
단단해요 그리고 정말 마음에 드는
부분인데 토글이 상체 쪽 세 개만
달려 있습니다 그래서 입고 벗을 때
체결하는게 크게 귀찮지 않고 무엇보다
앉을 때도
편합니다이어서 같이 소개해 드릴
제품은 르메르의 이번 이사 FW 시즌
라이너 자켓입니다 아마 르메르를 몇
시즌 전부터 좋아하신 분들이라 라면
라이너 자켓에 대해 잘 아실 텐데요
제 기억에는 2018년 FW 시즌에
그때 출시한 꼬냐 컬러가 엄청난
인기를
끌었었습니다 저는 당시에 대학생이다
보니까 바라만 보다가 이번 이사 FW
쇼를 보고 아 이번에는 놓치지
않아야겠다고
마음먹었습니다 이사 FW 시작하고
진짜 거의 매주 한남 르를 방문했어요
그때 장님이 랑 더 친해진 거 같은데
아무튼 입고 대고 바로 구매했습니다
라이너 자켓의 의미 자체가 최종
아우터 안쪽에 있는 것이다 보니까
디자인 자체가 편해 보이는 옷입니다
다만 알파카와 울 혼방으로 돼 있어서
보온성과 고급스러움을 모두 갖췄어요
개인적으로이 옷에 하나 아쉬운 건
검정 파이핑이 들어가 있다는 점인데
저는 예전 시즌 라이너 자켓처럼 좀
더 깔끔한 거기를 했어요 그래서
브라운으로 마음을 완전히 먹고
갔음에도 블랙은 파이핑에 티가 안
나서 고민을 많이 했습니다 라이너
자켓은 컬라가 없다 보니까 안에 어떤
걸 같이 있는지에 따라서 느낌이 많이
달라집니다 일단 오늘은 라이너 자켓의
브이존을 보여 드리기 위해서 안에도
브이넥 니트를 같이 입어 줬는데요
브이존이 명치 살짝 위쪽까지 옵니다
이전에 출시한 르멜 a 라이너 자켓들
비하면 좀 더 깊은 축에 속하는데요
실제로 이렇게 입으면 목이 횡하다
보니까 목도리를 둘러 주거나 아니면
부인액 니트 안에 터틀 렉을
레이어링해 주면 좋을 것 같습니다
라이너 자켓은 후드와 함께 입으면
정말 편한 룩이 완성되고 비슷한 톤의
셔츠를 입어 레이어링을 해주면 좀 더
깔끔한 느낌을 줄 수 있습니다
개인적으로는 후자를 더 선호해요
그래야 라이너 자켓 소재 고급스러움도
잘 부각되고 무엇보다 르에서 추구하는
우아함 잘 묻어난다고
생각합니다 라이너 자켓과 더플 코트가
같은 시즌은 아니지만 색감과 채도가
어느 정도 비슷해서 같이 입기
좋습니다 더플 코트는 좀 더 짧은
털로 되어 있고 라이너 자켓은 좀 더
길고 헤어리 하기 때문에 요철감이
있어서 차이가 있긴 합니다 겉으로만
봤을 땐이 코트는 꽤나 무거워 보여요
그런데 생각보다 정말 가볍습니다 제가
유니클로 질센더 더플코 하나고 있는데
두 제품을 비교했을 때이 르메르의
코트가 더 가볍고 더 따뜻합니다 이번
시즌 더플 코트도 입어봤는데 역시나
무겁지 않더라고요 제 경험상 르메
코트들은 대체로 착용감까지 고려해서
무게감이 덜한 것 같습니다이 제품은
맥시 더플 코트라는 장명 답게 좀
넉넉하게 나와서 최종 아우터다
실루엣을
보여주는데요 부담스러운 그 이불 같은
느낌이 아니라 딱 몸을 포근하게 감싸
주는 느낌입니다 저는 패딩을 자주
입는 편이 아니라서 아마 겨울에 가장
많이 입을 아우터가 아닐까
싶습니다 마지막으로 소개해드릴 제품은
제가 가장 아끼는 르메르 제품 중
하나인 르메르의 20fw 시즌
밀리터리
오버코트 제 기억으론 제가 처음으로
구매한 르메르 유니클로유 덕분의
르메르 좀 친근해졌습니다 시점에 당시
20fw 2 SS 옷들을 보고 너무
예뻐서 아 이제는 진짜 르메르를 하나
옷장에 들여보자
생각했습니다 르벨의 가격은 친근하지
않다 보니까 공식 홈페이지의 시즌오프
기간에 좀 오래 동안 입을 수 있는
코트를
구매했습니다 겉으로 봤을 땐 트렌치
코트처럼 얇아 보이는데 입어 보면
꽤나
튼튼합니다이 밀리터리는 이름에서도
느껴지듯이 바스락거리는 얇은 재질이
아니라 되게 두껍고 내구성이 좋은
편입니다이 코트는 맨 윗단추만 빼고는
전부 히든 버튼으로 되어 있어서 꽤나
정재된 분위기를 보여주는데요이 옷의
색감도 제가 좋아하는 계열의
회색이지만이 옷에서 가장 마음에 드는
디테일은 바로 팔입니다 어깨부터
시작해 손목까지 떨어지는 라인이 살짝
둥그이 르메르의 트위스티드 데닌
바지와 비슷한 패턴으로 보이는데요
어깨 위에서부터 시작해 손목 안쪽으로
끝나는 봉제가 팔의 선에 더
구조적으로 표현한다는 점이 상당히
마음에 듭니다이 옷을 처음 받았을 때
기장을 보고 엄청
놀랐어요 르메르 인심이 넘치는지
기장이 무자비하게 긴 거예요 처음에는
아까워서 수선하지 않고 입고 다녔는데
어느 샌가 보니까 제가 지하철역
계단에 다 청소하고 있더라고요 어쩔
수 없이 10cm 넘게
잘라냈습니다 이옷은 허리 벨트도 같이
있는데 저는 따로 안 하고 다닙니다
코트의 계절이 되면 길거리에 코트를
입고 다니는 분들을 봤을 때 가끔씩
그 벨트를 줄줄 끌고 다니는 분들이
있어요 저는 그게 너무 마음이 아파서
그냥 빼버렸어요
앞서 말씀드린 대로이 코트는 좀
두툼한 재질이라 한겨울 전까지는 입고
다닐 수 있습니다 어 깔끔하지만
무거운 클래식한 느낌의 코트는
보시다시피 아니기 때문에 캐주얼하게
후드티 등에 거치기도 좋고요 좀
차려입어야 하는 자리에 갈 때도
괜찮은 코트입니다 사실 어제 결혼식
갈 때도이 코트를 입고
다녔어요 이렇게 제가 애정하는 브랜드
르메르의 제품을 몇 가지 좀 소개해
봤습니다 앞으로 어떤 주제들을
말씀드리면 좋을까 틈틈히 생각해보고
적어놓고 있어요 궁금하신게 있다 면
댓글로 말씀해주셔도 좋습니다 오늘 제
이야기는 여기까지입니다 감사합니다